[Music]
poor Walker left a serious impact on
pretty much everyone involved in the
Fast and Furious franchise from baby Nam
tributes to heartfelt PSAs his co-stars
and loved ones have worked hard to honor
his memory speaking with Entertainment
Tonight Vin Diesel said that losing poor
Walker who he nicknamed Pablo was like
losing his own flesh and blood the two
didn't just grow their friendship into
her Brotherhood in the movies they
forged a real one that survived Beyond
Walker's passing in the ET interview
diesel made it very clear walk was more
than just a co-star what's the like
living
without your brother you know what I
mean it's not about making a movie
diesel has revealed that he felt he
played the role of a big brother on set
for much of the core cast especially in
those early films but claims that it was
Walker who taught him how to be a father
Walker's daughter Meadow was born in
1998 10 years before diesel welcomed his
first child into the world the actor
told Access Hollywood that for this
reason he relied on Walker for guidance
and support on his own journey through
fatherhood diesel went on to explain how
he felt Walker was even there in spirit
when his youngest daughter was born in
2015 to honor his old friend diesel
named her Pauline the feeling of
Brotherhood was clearly mutual as meadow
walker had Vin Diesel escort her down
the aisle in her father's place a source
even confirmed to US Weekly that Meadow
sees Diesel and his children as family
and turns to them for support during
difficult periods it's UNS surprising
then that she chose to have diesel at
her side for such a momentous occasion
it took well over a year after Paul
Walker's death from a sh Rodriguez to
speak openly about the loss of her
friend Rodriguez who plays lety Ortiz in
the Fast and Furious franchise described
Walker as the deepest guy she knew in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly she
revealed that his death was such a
horrific jolt that she completely fell
apart saying I felt like nothing I could
do could make me feel alive so I just
kept pushing myself harder and harder I
was traveling and I was having sex and I
was just trying to ignore everything
that I was feeling 6 years later
Rodriguez sat down to talk with tamon
Hall and seemed to be much more at peace
both mentally and spiritually the actor
had been suffering from anger issues and
substance abuse on top of her grief so
she took some time to herself to reach a
more stable state of being these days
when RZ works hard to maintain an open
mind about her existence and beliefs
feel that living it and traveling and
and really being curious and trying to
keep your heart open I think is the best
way to really learn she elaborated that
Walker's death was a quote reality check
and that losing such a close friend made
her question the driving forces behind
her professional Endeavors but RZ also
reflected that prior to Walker's death
she found herself living more
sporadically and exhibiting somewhat
dangerous behaviors however she
eventually set out to find more
sustainable Outlets to deal with her
feelings and she's a much happier and
more intentional person for it in the
Fast and Furious films Jordana Brewster
plays the part of Mia Toretto sister to
Vin Diesel's D and love interest to Paul
Walker's Brian throughout the movies
Mia's relationship with Brian evolves
and grows until eventually they start a
family together working so closely
Brewster and Walker shared a special
bond and in a conversation with US
Weekly Brewster shared that this bond
does not wne she explained that she
still thinks about a former co-star
constantly and tries to highlight what
an exceptional person she found him to
be Brewster went on to share her
favorite memory of working with Walker
on The Fast and Furious franchise
recounting a time that she ended up
needing stitches recalling a famous
scene in Fast Five in which she and
Walker had to jump across roofs in
Puerto Rico she explained I split my
hand open jumping from roof to roof in
Puerto Rico I was like I can keep going
because I wanted to have bravado in
front of Paul he was like yeah you're
being tough I'm so proud of you when we
wrapped I went to get stitches I
consider that my badge of honor Brewster
has kept honoring her relationship with
Walker throughout the years becoming
close with his daughter Meadow she told
us weekly that Meadow shares a lot of
similarities with her father and the
pair have gotten so close they even
attended each other's weddings Brewster
said that she takes a lot of pride in
seeing the woman her late friend's
daughter has become the Fast and the
Furious did exceptionally well at the
box office when it came out in 2001 but
it still faced several obstacles on its
way to becoming a blogbuster franchise
one major complication was that Vin
Diesel wasn't interested in returning
for a sequel so Too Fast Too Furious
went ahead without him despite Diesel's
absence po Walker's character Brian
returned to the franchise yelling into
Shenanigans down in Miami with his
childhood friend Roman Pier played by
Tyrese Gib
unfortunately for the actor when diesel
later returned Gibson's role fell by the
wayside he was excluded from the
following two Fast and Furious movies
speaking to the Toronto son Gibson
revealed that it was Walker who thought
for his character to be brought back
into the fold he explained when I wasn't
in number three or four every other day
Paul was saying we've got to bring tyres
back we've got to bring Roman back there
were certain people who were against it
and Paul campaigned to bring me back
paor walker single-handedly got me back
in the franchise for sure in other words
it seems that both Gibson and fans have
Walker to thank for Roman's return in
the franchise in Fast Five much like
diesel Gibson saw Walker as a brother
speaking with Entertainment Weekly he
explained that he still has a hard time
watching Furious 7 Walker's final film
due to the immense pain he feels from
the last he explained I have more bad
memories than good because all of the
fun and all of the magic that we had
going before Paul Walker's untimely
death the trauma of losing him
superseded all of them Chris ludicrous
bries as famous for his fast playful
raps however he has also built up a
respectable career as an actor with the
Fast and Furious film series being his
most well-known cinematic efforts
Bridges first appeared and Too Fast Too
Furious as tez a street fighter turned
Tech Guru and continued in that capacity
from the fifth film onward Tessa's
relationship with Brian OK Conor was
full of respect and the same was true
away from the cameras like so many other
members of the cast ludicrous considered
Walker family and he felt his loss
profound only speaking with Vibe ahead
of the release of fast 10 the actor and
musician revealed that while continuing
the series Without Walker has been
painful the challenges brought the rest
of the cast even closer he also
explained that with Walker Gan many of
the remaining Fast and Furious stars
took it upon themselves to continue
spreading the word about Walker's
philanthropic work to honor all the good
work he did in Life Bridges went on to
specifically credit Meadow is playing a
huge part in the continuation of
Walker's Legacy explaining to the outlet
he lives on through her and she's on set
with us a lot and offset as well
something you might not know about Sun
Kang's hanlu is that the character first
appeared in justtin Lynn's 2002 film
better luck tomorrow a movie about a
group of Asian-American High School
seniors who dipped their toes into the
world of crime Lyn brought the character
into the Fast and Furious franchise for
2006's Tokyo Drift while Han appeared to
die in that film that decision was later
Recon and K got the chance to work with
Paul Walker in subsequent movies and
surprisingly the two forms of type Bond
while collaborating speaking with the
Los Angeles Daily News Kang explained
that he often found it difficult to get
close with Costas saying that the more
movies he filmed the harder he found it
to form deep Connections in such a fast
moving industry he said that he found
paor Walker to be the exception to this
and explain that whether they were
working together or just hanging out he
felt Walker was always present and
earnestly attentive with his time in
2022 K directed a PSA that warned of the
dangers of driving irresponsibly there
was a spike in street racing during the
co 19 pandemic and like all the fast
family Kang knows that car accidents can
devastate lives the actor also did the
voiceover for the PSA which urged those
planning on taking to the streets to
race to go to designated tracks
instead sometimes we just want to get in
our cars and drive speaking about his
work on the PSA Kang told people I wish
our special effects could bring back our
loved ones but unfortunately that won't
be the case we are honored to be able to
be part of such an important message
stop racing on the streets and go to the
track playing the role of computer
genius Ramsey Natalie Emanuel joined the
Fast and Furious franchise for 2015's
Furious 7 this would be Paul Walker's
final film of the series and while
Emanuel didn't spend as much time with
him as her co-stars she still feels his
loss to this day in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly Emanuel described
how after Walker's tragic passing the
cast set out to make the films as great
as possible furthermore she believes
that the cast's for greatness that's
continued in the series later
installments and that Walker's Legacy
only grows with the franchise Paul was
such a huge part of it and you know he
lives still within it she cemented this
claim in a 2019 Instagram post in
advance of the release of F9 Emanuel
wrote how Furious 7 was her personal
favorite movie in the series and noted
how privileged she felt to have gotten
to work on Walker's final film in turn
Furious 7 director James ju also chimed
in saying that the moments that he
shared with Emanuel and Walker were some
of his favorite memories from making the
film much has been written about the
feud between Dwayne Johnson and Vin
Diesel but the former wrestler's
relationship with Paul Walker has been
less documented according to Johnson the
two actually bonded over their daughters
who are around the same age Johnson
doesn't speak publicly about Walker's
death very often but he felt compelled
to say something after another one of
his friends came close to suffering the
same fate in 2019 Kevin har to was
starred opposite Johnson and another
number of projects and even made a cameo
in Fast and Furious presents Hobs and
Shaw was involved in a serious car
accident that left him needing back
surgery in response Johnson published an
Instagram post on what would have been
Walker's 46th birthday he wrote recently
I got a scare when I almost lost another
friend on the road all this stuff got me
thinking about how beautiful yet wildly
unpredictable life is we never know
what's around the corner so we got to
live as greatly as we can in the honor
of our loved ones and ancestors who are
no longer with us he ended the C caption
with a salutation to Walker and
continued to pay omage to his former
co-star throughout the remaining Fast
and Furious films in which he appeared
by the time he died Paul Walker had
already filmed a majority of his scenes
of Furious 7 for the remaining shots his
brothers Caleb and Cody were brought in
to pose as his doubles their scenes were
then edited and POS with CGI to make the
change seamless after Furious 7 Cody who
is the CEO of poor Walker's Foundation
Reach Out worldwide began acting in his
own right and he as sense appeared in a
handful of projects including Sun Kang's
anti- street racing PSA guys let's be
responsible there's someone waiting for
you at home in a statement published
with the PSA Cody wrote about how
familiar he is with the pain of losing
someone in a car accident but he urged
viewers to consider the impact the
decisions on the road have and not just
themselves but their loved ones as well
echoing Kang's sentiment in the PSA he
went on to encourage those with a Need
for Speed to keep their racing on
designated tracks and out of the road
the legacy of Paul Walker both on screen
and off is forever interwoven with the
family that he forged in the Fast and
Furious franchise in the 2018
documentary I am Paul Walker the late
actor's family and friends speak with
love about his fearlessness his charm
and how much he has still missed that's
a legacy worth
[Music]
leaving